hey everyone we've got a quick
comparison here of the resident evil
village demo played on the playstation 4
and playstation 5. watch me get beat up
by werewolves and vampires
and let me know which console you'll be
playing on thanks for watching
in life and in death we give
glory uh hello
you shouldn't be out here it's not safe
what the hell hey can you hear me
it's you the child's father
child hey wait do you mean rose is she
here
yes she is in great danger
since mother miranda brought her to the
village we have fallen into darkness
what are you talking about the monsters
uh hello you shouldn't be out here it's
not safe
what the hell hey can you hear me
it's you the child's father
child hey wait do you mean rose is she
here
rose rose yes
she is in great danger
come on it's clear hurry hurry
took your damn time oh you're welcome
he's not used to relying on other people
i'm sorry
we'll be safe in here won't we safer
here than out there that's for sure
elena i
said no
oh my god i'm so sorry father
hey hey that wasn't your father anymore
you did the right thing
[Applause]
elena elena no there's nothing you can
do
this entire place is collapsing
you couldn't save him he was already
gone
leave me alone no we're getting out of
here
together
huh
i haven't cut open a man in a while
let me string you up slice your jugular
and just watch
take it alive dead witch would you
prefer
mother said sail but i think you're
[Music]
delicious
[Music]
you